BREAKING NEWS, OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
BEFORE I GET TO THE BREAKING
NEWS, AND THERE IS A LOT, I WANT
TO TAKE A MINUTE, I WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING.
I HAVE NEVER WITNESSED A SPEECH
ON THE U.S. SENATE FLOOR THAT
WAS AS POWERFUL AS THE SPEECH
TODAY GIVEN BY SENATOR COLLINS
OF MAINE.
HER REMARKS TODAY, I HAVE BEEN
INCIDENTALLY.
IN TALK RADIO 30 YEARS TOMORROW,
I BEGIN MY 23rd YEAR HERE AT FOX
NEWS CHANNEL.
I EVER WITNESSED IN THE U.S.
IT WAS, FRANKLY, THE BEST SPEECH
SENATE.
IT WAS AN EXAMPLE ON HOW ALL
SENATORS SHOULD MAKE DECISIONS
AND CONDUCT THEMSELVES.
SENATOR COLLINS WAS METHODICAL,
THOUGHTFUL, RESPECTFUL, CLEARLY
DID HER HOMEWORK, LAID OUT HER
JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY.
THAT OF JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
SHE SHOWED A GRASP OF THE
CONSTITUTION, SUPREME COURT
PRECEDENT, AND GAVE A CHILLING
AND SAD DESCRIPTION OF THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE’RE ALL
LIVING IN TODAY.
IT WAS TRULY A MODERN DAY
PROFILE IN COURAGE.
FRANKLY, I DON’T KNOW SUSAN
COLLINS, AND I DON’T KNOW HER
WELL AT ALL, I DON’T GET
IMPRESSED THAT OFTEN.
THE SPEECH TODAY, FRANKLY, BLEW
ME AWAY.
SHE SHOULD BE PROUD.
FRANKLY, IT HAD A LOT LESS TO DO
WITH HER DECISION, ALTHOUGH
THIS.
THAT’S VERY IMPORTANT IN ALL OF
THAN THE PURE HUMAN DECENCY,
FAIRNESS, AND PROCESS THAT SHE
EMPLOYED TO GET TO HER DECISION.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> TODAY, WE HAVE COME TO THE
CONCLUSION OF A COULD BE
FIRMATION PROCESS --
CONFIRMATION PROCESS THAT HAS
BECOME SO DISFUNCTIONAL, IT
LOOKS MORE LIKE A CHARACTER OF A
GUTTER LEVEL POLITICAL CAMPAIGN
THAN A SOLEMN OCCASION.
JUDGE KAVANAUGH HAS RECEIVED
RAVE REVIEWS FOR HIS 12-YEAR
TRACK RECORD AS THE JUDGE,
INCLUDING FOR HIS JUDICIAL
TEMPERAMENT.
THE AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION
GAVE HIM ITS HIGHEST POSSIBLE
RATING, IN EVALUATING ANY GIVEN
CLAIM OF MISCONDUCT, WE WILL BE
CLAIM OF MISCONDUCT, WE WILL BE ILL-SERVED IN THE LONG RUN IF WE
ILL-SERVED IN THE LONG RUN IF WE
ABANDON THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE AND FAIRNESS.
I LISTENED CAREFULLY TO
CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD’S
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
I FOUND HER TESTIMONY TO BE
SINCERE, PAINFUL, AND
COMPELLING.
THE FOUR WITH ITS SHE NAMED
COULD NOT CORROBORATE ANY OF THE
COULD NOT -- WITH ITS SHE NAMED
COULD NOT CORROBORATE ANY OF THEEVENTS OF THAT EVENING GATHERING
EVENTS OF THAT EVENING GATHERING
WHERE SHE SAID THE ASSAULT
OCCURRED.
NONE OF THE INDIVIDUALS
PROFESSOR FORD SAYS WERE AT THE
PARTY HAVE ANY RECOLLECTION AT
ALL OF THAT NIGHT.
THAT PRESIDENT -- THAT PROFESSOR
THE FACTS PRESENTED DO NOT MEAN
THAT PRESIDENT -- THAT PROFESSORFORD WAS NOT SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
FORD WAS NOT SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
THAT NIGHT OR AT SOME OTHER
TIME.
BUT THEY DO LEAD ME TO CONCLUDE
THAT THE ALLEGATION FAILED TO
MEET THE MORE LIKELY THAN NOT
STANDARD.
THESE CHARGES CAN BARELY PREVENT
THEREFORE, I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
THESE CHARGES CAN BARELY PREVENTJUDGE KAVANAUGH FROM SERVING ON
JUDGE KAVANAUGH FROM SERVING ON
THE COURT.
MR. PRESIDENT, I WILL VOTE TO
CONFIRM JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
>> Sean: I HAVE NOT ALWAYS
AGREED WITH SENATOR COLLINS.
EVEN SOME THINGS SHE SAID IN HER
SPEECH I DISAGREE WITH IN TERMS
OF PRECEDENT AND THE LAW.
THAT’S NOT THE ISSUE.
SHE BRAVELY RESTORED COMMON
SENSE, DECENCY TO THE U.S.
SENATE AND LED BY XWAM MANY.
AND SHE HAD TO STAND UP TO A
VERY ANGRY LEFT WING MOB, AND
SHE STOOD FOR PRINCIPLES THAT
MAKE THIS COUNTRY GREAT.
SHOWED REAL COURAGE.
SHE TOOK THE PROCESS FROM THE
BEGINNING SERIOUSLY.
SHE PROTECTED THE SANCTITY OF
THE U.S. CONSTITUTION.
DUE PROCESS, PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
AND IN DOING SO, SHE EXPOSED
WHAT IS THE HYPER PARTISAN
FRANKLY DESTRUCTIVE NATURE OF SO
MANY SMEAR MERCHANTS THAT EXIST
ON THE LEFT TODAY.
AND BY THE WAY, THERE ARE SOME
ON THE RIGHT, TOO.
SENATOR LINDSAY GRAHAM, GOING TO
BE JOINING NEWS A FEW MINUTES
WITH SENATOR TED CRUZ.
HE ALSO DESERVED A LOT OF
CREDIT.
HIS POWERFUL MOMENT LIT A FIRE
FOR TRUTH, JUSTICE, AND DECENCY
IN THE COUNTRY.
MANY DEMOCRATS PROCLAIM THEIR
OPPOSITION TO JUDGE KAVANAUGH
WITHIN SECONDS OF HIS
NOMINATION.
OTHERS UP ENDED THE HEARINGS
WITH ENDLESS INTERRUPTIONS,
GRANDSTANDING, THE WORST OF THE
WORST.
WORKS THE OF ALL, MANY DEMOCRATS
ACTUALLY WENT ALONG WITH
ACCUSING BRETT KAVANAUGH OF EVEN
BEING A IST, A -- A RAPIST, A
GANG IST.
NO -- RAPIST.
DRUGGING GIRLS ROUTINELY AT
PARTIES.
THEY CALLED HIM EVIL.
COMPARED HIM TO BILL COSBY.
MEN WERE TOLD TO SIT DOWN AND
SHUT UP.
ZERO CORROBORATING EVIDENCE.
BASED ON 36-YEAR OLD CLAIMS THAT
WERE BACKED UP BY NOBODY.
THE REPUBLICANS TOOK THIS
RIGHTLY SERIOUS, IT’S A SERIOUS
TOPIC.
LAWMAKERS, SOME OF THEM DIDN’T
CARE.
THEY WANTED TO RUIN A MAN’S LIFE
AND HIS REPUTATION FOREVER.
AND I’M PRETTY CERTAIN TONIGHT,
BRETT KAVANAUGH, HIS WIFE, HIS
TWO YOUNG DAUGHTERS, I’M SURE
THEY’LL NEVER BE THE SAME AGAIN.
WE AS A COUNTRY, COULD NOT
REWARD THIS MADNESS, MEANNESS,
INSANITY.
NOW, MANY ON THE LEFT ARE
LASHING OUT AT SENATOR COLLINS,
PREDICTABLY.
AN OPINION WEBSITE OWNED BY
UNIVISION, SPLINTER, PUBLISHED
"BLEEP SUSAN COLLINS."
NUT JOB, SO-CALLED KATHY
GRIFFIN, HAD THE SEVERED HEAD OF
DONALD TRUMP, TELLING COLLINS TO
GO TO HELL.
THE OFFICIAL TWITTER OF THE
WOMEN’S MARCH PUBLISHED THIS
PICTURE, CALLING HER, QUOTE, A
QUOTE RAPE APOLOGIST.
SO OVER THE TOP.
SO, SO DESPICBLY UGLY AND
DISGUSTING.
MANY OF THESE SAME PEOPLE THAT
CLAIM TO HAVE A MONOPOLY OF
COMPASSION, WOMEN, MINORITIES,
HUMAN, CIVIL RIGHTS, WOULDN’T
THEY BE SHOWING OUTRAGE IF ANY
CONSERVATIVE IN THIS COUNTRY
EVER SAID AND DID SUCH THINGS?
VERY DANGEROUS TIME FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
WEEKS PRIOR TO HER SPEECH, SUSAN
COLLINS HAD LEFT WING ACTIVISTS
SENDING THOUSANDS OF COAT
HANGERS TO HER OFFICE.
MADE THREATENING, DEROGATORY
COMMENTS TO HER STAFF.
TRIED TO BRIBE HER WITH A CROWD
FUNDING CAMPAIGN.
ANGRY MOB OF LEFT RING
PROTESTERS HARASSING SENATORS
ALL OVER CAPITOL HILL.
THIS IS GETTING DANGEROUS.
TAKE A LOOK.
[CHANTING]
SHAME, SHAME, SHAME, SHAME,
SHAME.
>> I’M VERY MUCH CONCERNED THAT
WE HAVE --
[ALL YELLING AT ONCE ]
[CHANTING]
>> Sean: LET ME SAY SOMETHING, I
BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE
CLOSE TO THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES.
IT’S SAD WHAT I’M ABOUT TO SAY.
BEFORE SOMEBODY GETS HURT, OR
WORSE, THESE OFFICE AREAS OF
ELECTED OFFICIALS NEED TO BE
CLOSED TO THE PUBLIC.
SAD, BUT IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
THIS IS DANGEROUS AND OUT OF
CONTROL.
AND OF COURSE THE LEFT
PREDICTABLY, ACTING OUT IN WAYS
ON TV THAT ARE FRANKLY
UNCONSCIONABLE.
MANY CASES ON SO-CALLED NEWS
NETWORKS.
TAKE A LOOK.
WHEN, NOT IF, WHEN JUDGE
KAVANAUGH HELPS THEM TO CHIP
AWAY AT CIVIL RIGHTS, VOTING
RIGHTS WORKS MEN’S RIGHTS,
ABORTION RIGHTS, I DON’T THINK
IT’S GOING TO SIT WELL WITH THE
COUNTRY.
>> DON’T FORGET THESE PEOPLE
WOULD GO TO CHURCH AND THEN GO
TO THE LYNCHING AFTER CLOTHING
THEMSELVES IN MORALITY.
THAT’S WHAT WE SEE TODAY.
>> CLEARLY THE REPUBLICANS DON’T
CARE ABOUT THE TRUTH.
THEY DID ONE INVESTIGATION INTO
WHO BRETT KAVANAUGH REALLY WAS,
THAT WAS GUTNESS.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE ARE WHERE WE
ARE.
THIS IS A TRAVESTY FOR AMERICA.
>> THE PROBLEM WITH AMERICA
RIGHT NOW, IS THAT WE’VE LOST
THE MORAL COMPASS.
>> Sean: FOR THE LAST 22 DAYS
WE, AMERICANS, HAVE WITNESSED
WHAT IS AN UNRIVALLED INSANITY,
OF MADNESS THAT’S TAKEN OVER.
AND IT’S NOW SHAKING THE VERY
CORE PRINCIPLES THAT EVERY ONE
OF US, DOESN’T MATTER IF
POLITICS, SHOULD BE HOLDING NEAR
AND DEAR TO OUR HEARTS.
RULE OF LAW, DUE PROCESS,
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
DEMOCRATS, WELL, ARE WE GOING TO
REWARD THIS BEHAVIOR?
SHOULDN’T PEOPLE BE FACING
CONSEQUENCES FOR WHAT IS RECNESS
ACTIONS?
SENATOR FEINSTEIN MAY BE THE
SUBJECT OF AN’ICS PROBE, WHO
LEAKED PROFESSOR FORD’S LETTER.
NOW WITH IT TAMPERING
INVESTIGATION SHOULD TAKE PLACE
AFTER CLAIMS THAT ONE OF
PROFESSOR FORD’S CLOSE FRIENDS,
WHO SHE LISTED TO CORROBORATE
HER STORY, ADMITTED TO THE FBI
SHE WAS BEING PRESSURED INTO
ALTERING HER STATEMENT?
ALL OF THIS ASIDE, IN 32 DAYS,
THERE IS NOW, WE’VE ALL LEARNED
SOMETHING.
THERE IS SOMETHING A LOT MORE
PROFOUND ON THE BALLOT THAN
ANYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT OR
TELLING YOU.
ON THE ONE SIDE, WE NOW HAVE ONE
PARTY IN AMERICA, I WANT TO
PURPOSELY EXCLUDE JOE MANCHIN OF
WEST VIRGINIA.
THAT HAD BECOME A PARTY, THAT
HAS BEEN OVERTAKEN BY THE FAR
LEFT.
THEY DON’T EVEN HAVE ROOM FOR
JOE LIEBERMAN IN THIS PARTY.
REMEMBER WHAT THEY DID TO HIM IN
CONNECTICUT.
I’VE KNOWN HIM FOR DECADES.
ONE OF THE NICEST PEOPLE YOU’LL
MEET.
WE HAVE NOW WITNESSED IN 22 DAYS
A TYPE OF GOVERNMENT THAT IS
A PARTY THAT CLEARLY STANDS FOR
ALIEN TO EVERYTHING THAT THIS
COUNTRY WE LOVE WAS FOUNDED ON.
A PARTY REJECTING AND SIMPLY
JUST HATING WHAT WE ALL THOUGHT
WE AGREED ON.
CORE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES.
REJECTING EVEN OUR CONSTITUTION.
DEMANDING FULL AND COMPLETE
CONFORMITY.
YOU DON’T AGREE, GOD HELP YOU.
A PARTY OF BLATANT DOUBLE
STANDARDS THAT CAN REMAIN
TOTALLY SAY LENT ABOUT GROSS
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST KEITH
ELLISON, BILL CLINTON, THEY LOVE
THE CLINTONS BUT PRETEND TO CARE
ABOUT WOMEN’S RIGHTS.
OBVIOUSLY SELECTIVE MORAL
OUTRANL.
ENVISIONS IDEOLOGY, AN AGENDA,
SPREAD THROUGH THE COURTS.
THEY WANT ACTIVIST JUDGES, THEY
WANT LEGISLATION THAT THEY COULD
WANT LEGISLATION THAT THEY COULDNEVER GET PASSED THEMSELVES DONE
NEVER GET PASSED THEMSELVES DONE
FROM THE COURT.
THEY DON’T WANT SEPARATION OF
POWERS.
THIS IS WHAT MADE THIS KWON
FIRMATION PROCESS SO POLITICAL.
IT SHOULDN’T MATTER TONIGHT,
THERE IS ZERO GLOATING HERE, OR
I WANT TO -- WANTED BRETT
KAVANAUGH TO WIN.
BECAUSE I THOUGHT HE DESERVED
THE POSITION.
AND I THOUGHT I AGREE WITH HIS
JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY.
I DON’T CARE IF YOU’RE A
REPUBLICAN, DEMOCRAT, LIBERAL,
CONSERVATIVE.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN WATCHING THE
LAST 22 DAYS IN THIS COUNTRY,
THIS IS NOT JUSTICE.
IN 32 DAYS FROM NOW, HUMAN
RIGHTS WILL BE ON THE BALLOT.
TREATING EVERY AMERICAN WITH
FUNDAMENTAL PAIR FAIRNESS,
RESPECT, EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE
LAW, EQUAL APPLICATION OF THE
LAWS.
THAT IS ON THE BALLOT IN 32
DAYS.
THINK OF THE SACRIFICE OF OUR
FOUNDERS, OUR FRAMERS, IN 32
DAYS AFTER WHAT WE HAVE NOW
LIVED THROUGH, THIS WILL BE
ABOUT AFFIRMING AMERICAN HISTORY
AND VALUES THAT THEY ALL
THOUGHT, BLED, DIED FOR,
SACRIFICED FOR US.
DUE PROCESS, PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, WHY IS THAT EVER
POLITICAL.
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS, CIVIL
LIBERTIES.
IN 32 DAYS, YOU, WE, THE PEOPLE
HAVE A CHOICE TO REAFFIRM THESE
HAVE A CHOICE TO REAFFIRM THESE VALUES, THESE PRINCIPLES THAT SO
VALUES, THESE PRINCIPLES THAT SO
MANY DIED FOR.
MANY BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN FOUGHT,
THOSE WHO UNDERSTOOD THE VALUES
OF FREEDOM AND JUSTICE, MADE
THIS COUNTRY GREAT AND SERVED US
WELL.
IN 32 DAYS THIS ELECTION IS
ABOUT PRESERVING ALL THAT IS
GOOD AND RIGHT AND JUST IN THIS
COUNTRY AND TAKING A STAND FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS FOR OUR
CHILDREN, OUR GRANDCHILDREN.
WHAT WE HAVE WITNESSED UNFOLD,
THESE LAST 22 DAYS, IS
ABSOLUTELY THE SINGLE MOST
DESPICABLE DISPLAY OF GUILT BY
ACCUSATION WE HAVE WITNESSED N32
DAYS, THIS IS ALSO ABOUT YOUR
LIFE.
RIGHT NOW, YOU ASK YOURSELVES,
ARE YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU WERE
TWO YEARS AGO?
BECAUSE BY EVERY REPORTABLE
OBJECTIVE DISCERNING MEASURE,
THIS COUNTRY IS NOW IN THE
MIDDLE OF A RECOVERY AND BOOM
THAT IS THE ENVY OF THE WORLD.
WE LEARNED TODAY, UNEMPLOYMENT
IN AMERICA, THE RATE DROPPED TO
THE LOWEST POINT IN NEARLY 50
YEARS.
1969, THE METS WON THE WORLD
SERIES, IT’S NOW 3.7%.
WE LEARNED THAT HISPANIC
UNEMPLOYMENT MATCHED THE RECORD
LOW.
ADD TO THAT HISTORIC LOW
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE AND YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT IN 14
STATES.
LOOK AT MANUFACTURING.
MANUFACTURING IS NOW NEAR AN
ALL-TIME HIGH.
4 PUN,000 NEW MANUFACTURING
JOBS, JOBS THAT THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION SAID WERE NEVER
COMING BACK.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE AT AN
ALL-TIME HIGH.
FOUR MILLION FELLOW CITIZENS,
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN WE
TALKED ABOUT SO MUCH OF IN 2016,
FOUR MILLION FEWER ON FOOD
STAMPS.
FOUR MILLION JOBS CREATED.
EIGHT MILLION AMERICANS OUT OF
POVERTY.
THE PROMISES OF THE PRESIDENT
THAT HE KEEPS, HIS TAX CUT, THE
LARGEST IN HISTORY.
BORDER WALL CONSTRUCTION, $3
BILLION ALREADY SPENT, HE’S
KEEPING THAT PROMISE.
THE PROMISE ON NAFTA, THAT WE
GET BETTER TRADE DEALS, PULLING
OUT OF OBAMA’S CAT SFROFIC
IRANIAN DEAL.
LOOK AT THE PROGRESS ON THE
KOREAN PENINSULA.
I DON’T SEE MISSILES FLYING OVER
JAPAN.
HE’S OPENED UP WHAT WILL BE THE
MIGHT AND PROSPERITY FOR ALL OF
AMERICA THAT COULD LITERALLY
HELP BRING ABOUT MORE PEACE THAN
WE EVER IMAGINED.
OF COURSE THE ENGINE OF R
ECONOMY.
WE HAVE MORE ENERGY, NATURAL
GAS, OIL, AND COAL THAN ALL OF
THESE OTHER COUNTRIES COME BIND.
FOR ALL OF YOU NEVER-TRUMP
REPUBLICANS, YOU HAD YOUR WAY,
NONE OF THIS WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED.
AND BY THE WAY, I’M TALKING
ABOUT YOU SO-CALLED CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICANS, WHO SAID I’LL NEVER
VOTE FOR TRUMP.
WELL, YOU CAN’T TAKE YOUR
VICTORY LAP TONIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
YOU ARE THE ONES OUT THERE
PODCASTING, WRITING BOOKS THAT
NO ONE BUYS, SELF-PROMOTING
YOURSELF PRO TRUMP, "JOHNNY COME
LATELIES."
YOU OWE THE REAL CONSERVATIVES
IN THE COUNTRY AN APOLOGY.
IF YOU HAD YOUR WAY NONE OF THIS
WOULD BE HAPPENING.
TONIGHT AS THE HORRIFIC
KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION PROCESS
GRATED, THIS ELECTION IS ABOUT
SO MUCH MORE THAN UNDOING THESE
INCREDIBLE TWO YEARS.
I’VE SAID IT BEFORE, IEL SAY IT